[Music]
Godzilla X Kong the new Empire is
already the fifth part of the so-called
monsterverse and is eagerly anticipated
by fans ever since the first teaser
trailer in early summer many have been
wondering what the Godzilla versus Kong
sequel is all about while the series
Monarch Legacy of monsters is being
released on Apple TV plus it's high time
for us to take a more detailed look at
the next movie and the future of the
monsterverse the big question of course
has to be what is Godzilla X Kong the
new Empire about according to official
sources Godzilla and Kong are up against
a colossal Menace hidden in our world
that threatens both them and Mankind the
movie is said to deal with the history
of the Titans and the secrets of Skull
Island it will also focus on the
legendary battles from which the
monsters emerged and which connect them
to humans what the affir mention threat
may be about becomes clear when we watch
the teaser trailer the video shows us a
red ape titan sitting on a majestic
throne in the mysterious Hollow Earth
around him lie the remains of other
Titans whose bones serve only as a
testimony to a bygone era his eyes glow
in intense blue reminiscent of the
energy of the hollow Earth towards the
end of the trailer we see the skulls of
Godzilla and Kong glowing in a
mesmerizing interplay of blue and yellow
light the presence of the Titan bones
around the throne suggests that this new
Kaiju is an ancient creature and perhaps
one of the few survivors of the massive
Kaiju War a first version of the movie
has already been screened to a test
audience its verdict the movie is
reminiscent of the Godzilla movies
belonging to the showa series this
describes the first Godzilla movies of
the ' 50s to 7s but even though Godzilla
is in the title he seems to play a
rather minor role this time the plot is
supposed to focus heavily on Kong it is
therefore probably no coincidence that
the Titan in the teaser is ape
Kaiju according to initial reports the
human actors in Godzilla X Kong the new
Empire are featured to a greater extent
than in the previous three movies this
will naturally make fans prick up their
ears humans are often regarded as the
weak point of monster movies in addition
to a compelling story the cast is
therefore particularly important this
time down Abbey star Dan Stevens is
assuming the lead role an actor with
quite a bit of experience Rebecca Hall
Brian Tyree Henry and Kaylee hodle will
reprise the roles from Godzilla versus
Kong they'll be joined by Irma V actress
F Chen East Ender actor Alex Ferns and
Rachel house who can currently be seen
in the Australian comedy series
heartbreak
High filming for Godzilla X Kong the new
Empire began about a year ago in
Australia on the scenic Gold Coast and
in the Southeast Queensland region the
first images from the set of the time
showed people fleeing on a beach
probably a scene that is supposed to be
set in kopa Cabana in Rio de Janeiro as
with its predecessor the movie was
directed by Adam winguard so we can
probably look forward to similarly epic
big screen action as in the successful
Godzilla versus Kong shooting of the new
monsterverse movie has been completed as
of November 2022 this is a good sign as
it gives a lot of time for post-
production and therefore particularly
impressive effects but when will
Godzilla xcong the new Empire be
released well the theatrical release of
the yearly awaited sequel is scheduled
for April 12th 2024 so the next trailer
shouldn't be too long
incoming that's everything there
currently is to know about Godzilla X
Kong the new Empire and Monarch Legacy
of monsters what are your thoughts on
the development of the monster verse and
do you have a personal favorite when it
comes to monster movies let us know in
the
comments
[Music]